the pressure on our nhs on our hospitals
is going to be uh considerable in the
course the next couple of weeks and
maybe more because as there's no
question omicron continues to to surge
through the country uh there's a couple
of important points it is it is plainly
milder than previous uh variants uh but
we're also in a different position we've
got plan b
in place people should never forget that
uh we've got the the measures that we're
we're using
making people wear masks on public
transport in confined places where
you're meeting people you don't normally
meet
those types of restrictions working from
home if you can working from home if you
can but we're also continuing the
massive booster rollout which you can
see happening here in in ellsbury today
and uh not just the the booster rollout
but the vaccination program for those
who haven't yet even had their first or
second vaccination i just want to make a
crucial point to to people who are
thinking about getting their booster
there
there are still quite a lot of people
who have had two jabs but haven't had
the third
a third jab really does make a big big
difference uh there are two million
slots just this week to get your booster
so get boosted now it can make all the
difference in the world the majority of
people who are in icu sadly uh have not
been uh vaccinated and certainly the
vast majority about 90 have not been
boosted
tell me you say that the data doesn't
support further restrictions but there's
increasing pressure on hospitals do you
accept it is a gamble i think the way
forward i think the way forward for the
country as a whole is to continue with
the path that we're on uh we'll keep
everything under review of course we
keep all measures under review but the
the mixture of
of things that we're doing at the moment
is i think the right one so number one
continue with with plan b make sure that
people take it seriously uh do what we
can to stop the the spread use the plan
b measures work from home if you can
wear a mask on public transport uh be
sensible about take a test before going
out to meet people you don't normally
meet uh think about the the the
requirements under plan b but also get
the the booster and i think that's the
difference between the uk and so much of
the rest of of europe and perhaps the
rest of the world we have a very very
high level of vaccination now and we
need to continue very fast to build up
those defenses and those uh that
protection in the population about 30
almost 34 million people 33.9 million
people across the uk have had a booster
amongst the the 70 uh to 75 group uh
you're looking at over 90 percent of
people have had it huge numbers uh i
think 76 percent of adults 76 percent of
adults so everybody who's thinking about
it get a booster you're joining the vast
majority
lincolnshire hospitals have declared a
critical incident now over staff
shortages is that a major factor in
terms of further restrictions staff
shortages
we've got to make sure that we look
after our nhs in any way that we can and
i've talked this morning to
amanda pritchard and
and steve palace uh and all those who
are running at the nhs i appreciate the
the pressures that our hospitals are are
under i think it's vital that we uh we
make sure that we we help them
by trying to contain the pandemic in the
ways that i've that i've set out so
do all the things that i've said make
sure we we follow plan b get boosted but
also help the nhs with their their
staffing requirements and and
we're looking at what we can do to to
move uh people into those areas that are
particularly uh badly affected but but
don't forget that
whatever no matter how uh
incredibly transmissible omicron is and
there's no question it really spreads
very very fast
it is different from previous variants
and it does seem uh
pretty conclusively to be less severe
than uh than delta or or alpha and uh it
is putting fewer people into icu and
sadly the people who are getting into
icu are the people who aren't uh who
aren't boosted so get boosted your
thoughts on cutting isolation to five
days as they have done in the united
states when you look at what we've we've
got in effect it's it's very close to uh
to that kind of limit anyway because
you're out on uh you know uh
one in the morning or uh just one minute
past midnight on uh on the on the day
that you you test uh you test negative
uh we'll continue to look at the
infectivity periods but the key thing is
we don't want to be
releasing people back into the workplace
when they're still infectious and the
risk is you'd increase the numbers of
people going back into the workplace who
are infectious by a factor of three so
you might perversely have a negative
effect on on the workforce if you saw me
so that's the that's the argument we're
looking at um a word about face masks in
schools as children go back to school
pupils go back to colleges this week
face masks in schools in england some of
your mps have been saying that you know
there's the efficacy is questionable
about them what would you say to them
on the other hand there are those
increasing body of scientific support
for the idea that face masks can contain
uh transmission we don't want to keep
them i don't like the idea of having
face masks in classroom any more than
anybody else does we won't keep them on
a day more than is necessary and just
one final question prime minister are we
at the beginning of the end of the
pandemic
i think that the the uk is in a in a
much much stronger position than uh this
time last year and there's there's no
doubt at all
and that is basically because of science
and because of a vaccination and
my view is that omicron is and it's it
seems to be uh born out by all the
evidence omicron is much milder
considerably milder than uh than
previous variants and we're much more
boosted so our position
is far far better but looking i think
this is what i would say to to everybody
looking at the pressures on the nhs in
the next couple of weeks
and maybe longer looking at the numbers
of people who are going to be going into
hospital it will be absolute folly to
say that this thing is all over now by
the shouting we've got to remain
cautious we've got to stick with plan b
we've got to get boosted